why hello
there i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message
for december 15 2020 that's right
it's only 10 days from christmas which
means
it's nine days from canceling christmas
you understand they're not gonna want
you to spend christmas with your family
if you don't get it i don't know what to
tell you at this point
santa is going to have to live in a
bubble they're going to just send bubble
santa down the chimney he'll get stuck
there
that'll cause a whole problem we got a
real situation on our hands
the lunacy continues and we're going to
devote
most of this show this is a very special
episode
of the reuben report direct message
because we're devoting most
of this show to the man who i suppose
is now president-elect 78-year-old
broken foot has a cold joe biden
because he is now officially
president-elect that doesn't mean the
whole thing is done and by the way there
still
are court cases there's all this
weirdness with dominion that everyone
is still talking about online but
nobody's talking about in mainstream
media which is part of that reality war
thing i'm always talking about
but in effect at the moment joe biden
is president-elect and we're going to do
a bunch about joe biden today because i
think there's a bunch
that you should know uh before we get to
it quickly though i want to tell you
guys that tonight
the reuben report community is doing a
movie night we are going to be watching
v
for vendetta which i think is as
perfectly
on point a movie as you could possibly
watch these days
uh that'll be at 5 00 p.m pacific 8 p.m
eastern this is for members of the
reuben report community only we're going
to be doing a netflix watch party so
hundreds of us
will be watching all together and then
we're gonna do a massive zoom call and
you guys can zoom in and
and we'll all be on video and i'll be on
video obviously and we'll talk about the
movie so you can join us
uh at reubenreport.com and find out
more information and before i get to
president-elect joe biden and his many
problems and confusions
i want to talk to you guys about glint
pay you know it i've got the card right
here and again this is not my official
card this is a mock-up card so even if
you're zooming in
to steal my info it ain't gonna work
people uh glimpey is a really fantastic
way of getting into the gold game you
can buy
and you can sell gold using their app
and then you can use the glint pay card
which is also a mastercard
to make purchases in either gold or
as the mastercard in us dollars it's a
fantastic way to just get involved in
doing something monetarily that maybe is
a little out of your comfort
uh but then keeps you a little less
reliant on the usual
ways of doing things so you can get the
glint pay card
at glintpay.com ruben the glint card
is issued by sutton bank which is a
member of the fdic pursuant to license
from mastercard international
it's free to sign up so go to
glynnpay.comruben for more info
and to start purchasing gold today
that's glinpay.com
ruben to get your gold today and now
back to me and just as a reminder guys
you can buy literally anything
anything that your mastercard would
allow you to buy you can buy it with
gold or cash there you go all right
let's talk about joseph r biden the man
from scranton
sometimes uh he has in essence
secured his win and is now the
president-elect
there is still stuff happening i will
keep talking about it
while most people ignore it i actually
don't think this thing is fully over yet
i just don't and even if i did think it
was over if there were things going on
in the courts i would still be willing
to talk about them
i know this is going to cost me friends
i know i know i'm a crazy conspiracy
theorist just trying to
give you the information that's actually
happening right now uh but
what am i going to do i'm crazy what can
i tell you uh so
let's get to the quote from fox news
here about president-elect biden
president-elect biden received 306
electoral votes to president trump's
232 which is the exact margin of victory
that trump won four years ago when he
defeated hillary clinton
in the popular vote biden received
almost 81.3 million votes
compared to 74.2 million votes for trump
so according to these numbers
that we're getting uh we're supposed to
believe that in essence about seven
million votes
separated these two even though there
was incredible enthusiasm for trump
there were massive rallies
we know about walkaway movements and
blexit and just the
ton of people and i've met them over the
last two years
tons of people who were democrats who
then were trump supporters there's
virtually no version of that
people that were hillary supporters uh
that or people that were trump
supporters last time that suddenly
became
biden supporters this time like there
was no walk away from the republican
thing there was the never trumpers but
they did the never trumpers
and the lincoln project guys they didn't
vote for trump in the first place
so but this is what we're being told
81.3 million
for joe biden 74.2
for trump uh i should note that obama
in his re-election year got 65 million
votes so
that means i'm not a mathematician here
but that means that according to my math
joe biden who didn't campaign who had no
enthusiasm for his campaign who really
nobody was interested in who's not a
good candidate who's 78 years old
who has dementia now has a broken foot
and a cold we'll get to that in a minute
got 16.3 more
16.3 million more votes than barack
obama who was the media darling hope and
change everybody loved him and
everything else like
if you believe that i don't know i got i
got a bridge to sell yeah
it just that just seems absolutely
crazy to me but that's what we are being
told to believe that joe biden is 16.3
million more votes popular than barack
obama even though in essence he had to
run
against obama in a certain respect right
he had to run against
because if any of the things that obama
had done for eight years
uh worked well then there would be no
need for joe biden right the stuff would
have worked trump couldn't have
destroyed all that in four years
anyway biden gave a speech last night
now that he is the president-elect
and uh he's having some problems let's
take a look and once again
the american america the rule of law
more americans voted this year
than have ever voted in the history of
the united states the votes counted
and pence received when they won in
2016.
excuse me or dispute
the results margin four years ago
and yet i thank them and i'm convinced
we can work together for the good of the
nation
on many subjects that's the duty owed to
the people
to our constitution to our history
you know in this battle for the soul of
america
democracy prevailed we the people voted
faith in our institutions held the
integrity of our elections remains
intact
and now it's time to turn the page as
we've done throughout our history
to unite to heal as i said in this
campaign
i will be president for all americans
i'll work just as hard for those of you
who didn't vote for me
as i will for those who did there's
urgent work in front of us
getting his pandemic under control and
getting the nation vaccinated
against this virus i mean if you think
there is a chance in high health that
that man is going to be president for
four years
i mean come on people what are we doing
he has a broken foot
he has some sort of dementia right he
can just read a teleprompter not that
well he still slurs a lot of words and
gets confused
and sometimes reads the other messages
like scroll
up that are on the teleprompter and
everything else but putting that aside
well now they're saying he has a cold
you know his wife dr
jill biden thank god he's married to a
doctor right she has now said
that he has a cold so he does have a
cold i'm guessing in a couple weeks
we'll find out he probably has covet or
something else
there is no chance in high hell that
this guy is going to be president for
more than a year even if he is to be
sworn in
on january 20th or they'll basically
just lock him up
and they'll they'll issue statements or
he'll have to do things only off
teleprompter from a bunker there'll be
no live questioning
it's just so freaking obvious i don't
know what to tell you but he's he's not
well and imagine if anyone else was
talking
all the time they were talking and
they're giving the biggest
speech of their life and i'm going to be
president for
everybody and also you're not supposed
to cough in your hand
he's coughing in his hand the whole time
and you know we have improved integrity
detection
the integrity of the election
this is uh this is just i just
don't think he's going to be president i
really don't and i certainly don't think
he'll last as president if that's to
happen
uh but we've got we've got more on joe
coming up in just a sec but before we
get to that guys i want to talk to you
about bill barr and why do i want to
talk to you about it
because the holidays are coming and i've
got three count them three
built bars in front of me right now are
you looking for a new protein bar that
tastes like a candy bar
well i've got just the brand for you
bill bars are super tasty
and come in 18 amazing flavors my
personal favorite is cookies and cream
which i don't even have oh no i've got
the coconut almond here i've got the
raspberry
and i've got the banana bread people but
as you know i like the cookies and cream
bill bars are covered in 100 chocolate
include both nut and nut free flavors
and are soft and easy to chew
with the holidays just around the corner
it's easy to slip up which is why built
bars are the perfect alternative
to pie for the health conscious guy i
can actually lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a delicious treat
built bars are low calorie low sugar
high protein and high fiber
go to builtbar.com and use promo code
ruben and you'll get 20
off your first order use promo code
ruben for 20 off your first order at
billbar.com good for built bars bill go
or bill boost
and now back to me
america okay uh all right let's uh throw
to this clip this is this is something
this is from bill hemmer reports on fox
news they got
some audio of joe biden talking about
how the
crazy leftist progressive squad
aoc policy of defund the police how this
really
mangled them and then of course he
devolves it into something else
let's listen in they've already
labeled us as being defund the police
anything we put forward in terms of the
organizational structure
to change policing which i promise you
will occur
promise you just think to yourself and
give me advice whether we should do that
before january 5th because that's how
they beat the living hell out of us
across the country saying that we're
talking about defunding the police
we're not we're talking about holding
them accountable
all right so there's some interesting
stuff there so in essence he's saying
that the defund the police thing was a
disastrous idea we all know that and i
just want to be very clear here
i dave rubin of the reuben report 100
stand with our police officers who are
doing the best job they can
under under extraordinarily difficult
circumstances with cameras in their face
constantly i know the media
and a political elite that's trying to
take them out does that mean that every
police officer is perfect of course not
our mistakes made
are there a couple of bad apples of
course but by and large
i know police officers i talk to a lot
of police officers i get emails from
police officers these are good people
who go into public service to serve the
public and maintain the law and order
that allows us to have a free society
right you can't have a free society
if you don't have law and order police
officers have been have been
just attacked mercilessly and told that
they're racists
and they're evil and all of those things
and it's absolute nonsense but in
essence what biden's saying there is
partly right
so first he's saying well the defund the
police thing is no good
and maybe we shouldn't have gone all in
on it and let the progressives run
run ramp shot which is what they do with
everything they just wreck
everything but then he sort of he gives
an interesting little piece he says
that that is what got us to have the
beat the living hell out of us
in essence meaning the republicans beat
the living hell out of us and as we know
the republicans did extremely well down
ticket i think picked up something like
28 seats can we fact check that let's do
a live fact check
how many uh seats did the republicans
pick up i mean people were saying that
the democrats were going to pick up
seats
that's what nancy pelosi was saying but
the republicans actually picked up seats
now that's also one of the odd things of
this election
that generally the top of the ticket
meaning the president and then the rest
of the seats that these things
are correlated but somehow this time
we're told we're
expected to believe that the president
got crushed
in the election and yet republicans who
were
in many cases campaigning on behalf of
him or campaigning on virtually the same
ideas the same platform
same party stuff that they did
incredibly well i think it's 28 seats
that they picked up i'm not totally sure
we're checking for it now um i think the
bigger
issue here with this defund the police
thing is that the damage has sort of
already been done
i've talked a couple times about this
new d.a that we have this new district
attorney that we have
here in los angeles who's literally
telling
people right now he's putting out a new
policy which is that in essence they are
not going to prosecute
crimes they are not going to prosecute
prostitution they are not going to
prosecute trespassing
they are not going to prosecute
resisting
arrest i mean really think how crazy
that is that means you could break into
a car
a cop could see you doing it and then if
you resist him
punch him run away throw something at
him threaten him
you're good to go that means that
somebody i talked about this on the greg
gutfeld show this weekend
somebody could hop the fence at my house
that means they're trespassing
they could solicit prostitution from my
front lawn
okay and then if they get arrested if i
call a cop
well then they can arrest duret resist
arrest do you see how absolutely crazy
that is
absolutely crazy um a little update on
the on the house because we do some
fact-checking on the fly as of right
this moment cnn has projected that
democrats have won 219 seats
the republicans have been uh projected
the winners in 203 seats but the
disparity was supposed to be much bigger
there i'm pretty
i'm pretty sure the republicans picked
up 28. and i have no doubt that you guys
will fully fact check me on that so
that'll
that'll be just fine the point is that
the republicans did really well down
ticket
which nobody predicted and the fact that
that seemingly
is disconnected from what happened at
the top of the ticket
just seems very bizarre
in addition to all of the other uh very
bizarre things that
that happened in the course of this
election all right let's move on to the
next segment
uh so this will be really interesting so
you know one of the things
that i kept saying about the biden
campaign as long as we're focusing on
on biden today although segment four is
going to be a little different
um one of the things that i kept saying
is that the candidacy really made no
sense
because the whole idea of the
progressive movement
and and everything that they've put
forth
is that america is fundament
fundamentally flawed
the founding is evil our institutions
are evil
racism bigotry all of these things
things that
we have done absolutely extraordinary
work in conquering
they believe are the driving forces of
what
of what makes america meaning we have we
have in essence eliminated bigotry
the new bigots are all the ones on the
left i mean it's the anti-racists who
are now the racists
those are the ones that want to put
bigotry and equity
and all of these things back into the
system right
there there's virtually nobody on the
right there is certainly no mainstream
conservative that wants different laws
for different people that wants to
punish people
based on the color of their skin or
their gender or anything like that
we're seeing that though on the left you
guys know about the proposition that we
had here
in los angeles which of course i voted
against which was going to reverse the
civil rights act
because in the civil rights act of 1964
they said you can't discriminate based
on skin color and everything else in in
federal jobs
well they were literally trying to
reverse that here fortunately even in
this banana state enough people said no
we're not going to do that right now
but these people are trying to get us
all to do hiring based on skin color and
sexuality and gender
and the rest of it so this is why the
biden campaign didn't make sense because
if biden had accomplished
anything in his 47 years in
office where he was a senator for most
of those years then eight years as vice
president
if he had accomplished anything then
america wouldn't be this fundamentally
evil place that the democratic base
believes it to be so that's one thing
and then the second thing of course is
well if you're trying to bring in new
blood
if you're trying to say okay all of that
stuff was bad well it's also a serious
condemnation
of the vice president for eight years
and it's and it's i've said
extraordinary a couple times here it's a
um colossal condemnation of barack obama
who was the
the hero of the progressive left right
he was the hero
but in essence biden saying oh i guess
he didn't really get anything done and i
was his teammate
you know i was his scottie pippen he was
the michael jordan we didn't really do
anything
so now i have to run to fix all of the
stuff that he didn't do so
to me the candidacy made no sense on top
of 78 year old
dementia coughing constantly and the
broken foot and everything else right so
none of it really made any sense but now
what we're seeing is actually what this
seemingly was all about
so let's throw to this quote from npr i
don't like to quote npr often but i
think they they got this one right
because it was seemingly just facts here
it's amazing
as president-elect joe biden crafts his
cabinet and white house team of advisors
he has pledged to make it the most
diverse team in history but in his pick
so far there is one thing that most of
his team will have in common
service in the obama administration so
let's throw this image up there
12 of the 16 people that have been
selected
so far to be in his cabinet again if
this cabinet is to take office if joe
biden is to be sworn in as president
12 of the 16 people were obama people
so we are literally just bringing the
swamp
back that is what this thing really was
about so you know
one of the things that a lot of people
talked about over the last couple years
is sort of what is the dnc at this point
like who really is in charge of the dnc
like the hillary machine the clinton
machine was in charge of it for a while
right it destroyed
bernie sanders we know that that
happened last time and then he just
became a neutered pet this time and i'm
actually okay with that right because i
think i think bernie and his ideas are
are pretty terrible um but i think what
we've now seen is that there's been a
shift
in what the dnc is it's gone from being
the clinton machine and now it's just
the obama machine so you're just
going to get a second term of obama by
the way what that will include our drone
strikes we'll probably go back
to some wars we're going to have an ever
expanding government
apparently obamacare wasn't right so
biden's going to do an even better
job with that i just heard right before
we started like a minute before that
pete bootage is going to be
transportation sector secretary
he was he was a mayor in indiana i mean
he has no experience doing any of that
but he's gay so we got some diversity
um you get it like we're going to bring
back uh susan rice
um they're just uh wait what did susan
rice call me out what did suzerai say to
me once on twitter
she what what was it susan rice went
after me once on twitter for being pro
oh yeah because she said i'm pro-life or
so
i tweeted something very like i don't
even remember what it was maybe maybe we
can find it we'll throw it up tomorrow
if we can't find it right now
i tweeted something once and tweet and
susan rice tweeted back at me something
in effect like i'm a far right pro life
conservative or something like that
anyway
it doesn't matter the point is the the
swamp is coming back we're now seeing
that the biden thing
is just this giant government oh
yes susan rice what was she responding
to me let's get this full thing here
michael's helping me out at the moment
i had retweeted ben shapiro i think
right is that what this was
i had retweeted ben shapiro about
something and
she retweeted me and she said i thought
these idiots
were pro-life so she called me a an
idiot what is what is her potential
job in the administration let's let's
find that out because somebody in the
administration
has called me and ben shapiro idiots
what am i going to do what am i going to
do on top of the fact that i've got my
governor and my mayor trying to hunt me
down because i made a delicious
lamb leg for a few people the other
night i've said too much
uh she is looks like she's going to be
the domestic policy council director
that's susan rice
anyway the point is that these people if
you weren't sure
what the biden thing is going to be it's
going to be
some basically far left thing
without like the full far left
credentials so they what biden has done
here it's pretty slick actually right
it's like you're obviously ushering in
all of this stuff and he's obviously not
in charge like let's just be very clear
about that the idea that 78 year old
joe biden is really making these
decisions is nonsense but the move
the optics move that they made to make
this palatable
was pretty clever instead of bringing
bernie on where people would have said
this is
this is far left instead of bringing
elizabeth warren on where people would
have said this is far left what did he
do he brings
this uh kamala harris who was holding
literally at zero percent in her own
primaries right she was
out early nobody liked her but she
wasn't thought of as one of the crazy
lefties and she loves government she
loves jailing people
so i guess that makes her a moderate
democrat something like that and now you
start bringing in all the obama people
and now i don't know if you guys saw
this but black lives matter their
official twitter
account um they're very angry abiding
because for 37 days or something since
he's been
elected elected president they've
he's refused the biden administration
the biden president-elect administration
the office of the president-elect
they've refused to have a meeting
with black lives matter so he's doing
something very clever here he's saying
okay we're going to take all of the
policies of the far left
but just to make it more palatable to
the average idiot basically
we're not gonna be on you know we're not
bringing
uh bernie we're not bringing elizabeth
warren we're probably not bringing the
squad people
we'll just do what they want and make it
look more more palatable so it's it's
it's dangerous and it's playing with
fire uh and
and again i just don't think this thing
is over yet i
i just don't uh but if you want to see a
perfect example of how radical
things have become right um and i try
not to be alarmist on this show i try
not to
to you know put up all of the videos
trust me there's plenty of videos i
could put up all the time that would
keep everybody
in a constant state of craziness right
any of you who are on twitter you see
these videos all the time
but if you want to see how dangerous
identity politics is
how dangerous the idea that we should be
looking at our skin color more than
anything else
well over the last couple of months we
started suddenly started hearing about
the black national anthem
now i have no problem with anyone
writing any song that they want
i have no problem with whap with her
and her wet
stuff and the bucket and the whole thing
i have no problem with that i have no
problem with anyone singing about
whatever they want to sing about
i have no problem with anyone writing
what they call a black national anthem
i suppose i wouldn't have well if you
create a white national anthem we got a
whole other set of problems but
you could do whatever you want as an
artist if you create a white national
anthem a black national anthem i think
in the media we'd be treating these
things very differently
right because we're supposed to like
really have some respect for this new
black national anthem i'm pretty sure we
wouldn't be doing that
for the uh white national anthem uh but
putting that aside
uh there's there's been talk over the
last couple months
of the black national anthem which just
sort of appeared out of nowhere no one
had heard of this black national anthem
then it appeared out of nowhere then
there was talk that this could be maybe
played before football games
now i just want to be very clear about
something we are one nation
we are a series of states the united
states and what's the key word there
united we are united into one thing lots
of things
states and then we have one thing and we
are the united states of america that is
a beautiful thing
we are one nation we have political
disagreements
we have uh policy disagreements and the
rest of it and and i think we have some
stuff that's that's seriously structural
now that is a big problem but we are the
united states at least for now and that
means we have one national anthem and
you all know the national anthem
well uh yesterday or the day before at
the
michigan electoral college as they were
selecting their electors
they began not with the national anthem
they did play the national anthem but
they began
with the black national anthem let's
play a little bit
of the black national anthem now please
remain standing for the national anthem
and the black national anthem by the
turner sisters
jalia and jamylah turner
[Music]
let our rejoice
rise high as a good isn't it
skies let it
resound
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so let me be clear about a
couple things here i have no problem
with those two girls the turner sisters
they've got lovely voices if they're in
any way
related to tina turner then i really
love them because you know how much i
love tina turner what's love got to do
with it
um but this is a
courthouse in michigan where we are
selecting electors
for the national election we should not
be playing
a national anthem for a people of a
specific color that's that's not what a
national anthem is
a national anthem is for all of the
people in the country and we have one
already
the idea that a government official told
people to stand up
for an alternate national anthem is a
problem
that is a problem and we are going to
see more and more of this and by the way
michael just pointed out to me that
alicia keys actually sang this song
before an nfl game in september
when they showed a montage that featured
colin kaepernick
now again i don't care if alicia keys
wants to sing this song i don't care if
she wants to call it the black national
anthem
but should we be showing in essence
a separatist national anthem at our nfl
games
in our courthouses and everything else
now you know my feelings on the nfl
it's a private organization if they so
choose well then you can decide if you
want to support it you can decide if you
want to buy the jerseys and if you want
to watch the
the games and attend the games and
everything else and by the way we know
that
all of our national sports nba nfl and
everything else they're all crumbling
because they've all decided
to go woke we know that
that espn's ratings are collapsing
cratering because they're going woke
but they can do that it is very very
different when you're doing this in
governmental
courthouses state courthouses federal
courthouses by the way the song was
written in 1900 it's not a new song
but again i have no problem whether
alicia keys is or or the turner sisters
or whoever else is singing the song
you do it on your own time not in the
government and and
the problem is that we don't have adults
anymore this is
this is simply the truth how many people
think about
how many people you could name that are
in government that you think
are adults that you think are adults
that you think
can actually help guide us and help get
us to something more true and more real
and more
more directly connected to our founding
documents the things we're supposed to
be governed by as opposed to being
governed
by just whatever the whim of the day is
you know what i mean like now it's okay
boys have vaginas girls have
penises we're gonna have national
anthems for people of a certain color
like this is
all insanity but we don't have enough
adults
to counter it the the liberals i mean
you know my feelings on this the the
good liberals that should have stood up
and i and i calling out my own crew here
that for when when the idw the
intellectual dark web was blowing up
we had a massive moment to figure out
how to fight back and and i guess it
didn't work i did
you know i did everything i could do and
i'll continue to do that but the
liberals have been decimated there are
no liberals anymore in effect if you're
if you're a liberal if you're an old
school liberal in an american sense in
effect you're a new school conservative
right what do i what do i always say
it's defending my liberal principles as
becoming a conservative position so i
would say if anything i'm really a
modern conservative
at this point because ironically
conservatism is the thing defending
liberalism
the idea that we're going to have
science that will be based
on race not good the idea that we're
going to have
alternate national anthems not good the
idea that we're going to teach critical
race theory again
in schools horrific the idea that we're
going to bring
back title ix and we're not going to
protect students who are accused
of sexual harassment on college campuses
we're going to get rid of due process
all of these things are ushering back in
right now under a biden administration
on top
of the fact that the lockdowns seemingly
won't go away i just saw a headline in
the new york times
that now that they're saying now they're
saying well even if you get the vaccine
the 95
vaccine right this vaccine will work on
night for 95 percent of people
on a virus that has a 99 recovery rate
you still could be asymptomatic and
transmit it so you should still wear
masks
again i just this is just my belief this
is just my belief
at this point none of this has anything
to do with covet anymore we are
in what ben shapiro in his last book
quite
aptly described as a disintegration
we're in a disintegration of our
institutions our media our political
institutions and everything else
and is it bizarre do i find it bizarre
that donald trump is the last guy
standing up against it
it's weird man it feels like a sci-fi
movie i don't know what
to say about it but but there's just
there's just almost nobody left i feel
like i'm not giving you guys
everyone always messages me after these
and says oh i felt so great after
you make the news palatable you're
smiling and everything's gonna be okay
i ultimately do think everything will be
okay actually um because i believe that
the course of human history is a
it's a long fight it's a long fight and
good people are waking up
absolutely every moment along the way
they
really really are waking up and by the
way i'm going to do an interview a
little later today that we're going to
post just a quick on the fly interview
if you didn't see this viral video
yesterday this guy at nick's greek grill
in ventura county
which is about an hour away from here he
had the regulators come in and try to
shut him down
and the video went viral him fighting
back because these are just these middle
management regulators who've done
nothing
so think about this you have politicians
who are getting paid right now
to stop other people from working and
then you've got regulators these people
have couldn't
accomplish anything if their lives
depended on it they're nothing they're
they're little gestapo agents
in essence shutting down people who are
trying to make a living well he fought
back
uh we contacted him it turns out that
there's a knicks greek grill
a little closer to us in l.a i'm doing a
hundred dollar lunch
for my team today we're gonna eat a lot
of gyros how many falafel can dave rubin
fit in his mouth we'll find out in about
an hour
um but we're gonna do an interview with
him just a quick on the fly 10-15 minute
interview
and and like this guy anton who who is
the the owner of a couple of these
knicks grills
these knicks greek grill restaurants
good people who are not politically
politic uh
particularly political are waking up
right now and with
i think i really believe if we just keep
fighting and you do what you do
whatever it is you can do in your life
to keep fighting at the moment that's
the only thing like
the calvary is not coming there is no
magical thing that's coming yes could
lawsuits change things
could could something can some
structural things get a little bit
better could there suddenly be good
better politicians maybe i don't know
maybe
the way we turn this around is by all of
us getting involved and stop being
afraid and fighting for whatever you
fight for
do it in your own life i just see no
choice i don't think i'm that great i
don't think i'm particularly brave
for some reason i went down i went down
that road
and once you go down that road you
really can't turn back
because there's usually scorched earth
behind you not because you want the
scorched earth
but the people who don't like you or
scorching the earth behind you anyway
with all of this in mind uh we are going
to do something fun tonight the reuben
report community is doing a netflix
watch party we are watching v for
vendetta
at 5 p.m pacific 8 p.m eastern that's
for paid subscribers at reubenreport.com
so you can jump over there right now
and join us and get all the info and
then we're doing a giant zoom chat after
uh and we'll make some popcorn we'll
have some drinks and the rest of it
so check that out and you can also watch
part one of my interview with abigail
schreier who wrote this really wonderful
book on
the sudden craze of young teenage girls
who are suddenly transitioning to boys
and how this is this is a systemic
issue in that it's coming from our
medical community it's coming from our
educational community it's from coming
from
our media institutions anywhere else
where suddenly there's an issue where
there wasn't
an issue before i had an hour-long
conversation with you i assure you
she is not a transphobe she doesn't have
an irrational fear of trans people
but she does have a scientific lens to
look
at what is going on here and it's a
really fascinating
interview i hope you'll check it out all
right everybody have a great
day and hopefully i'll see you guys
tonight on zoom later